There's a multitude of ways to discover Mazatlan.
Today, we're going to do it the fun way on the fun bus,..
...followed by an art history walking tour.
Let's have some fun.
All these guys, early in the morning, five, six o'clock in the morning,...
...they go straight out to the islands.
They do some fishing.
They come over here.
They get your fish, clean it up, scale it and sell it to you by the pound.
Now for some art and history.
Welcome to Mazatlan.
This is our art museum and across the street is our archeological museum.
Let's go see some art.
Well, with the Artwalk, it's created a lot of interest in art and the artist,...
...and more and more artists are moving in because they're realizing...
..."Hey, this is a nice little artist haven we've got going."